vous avez été mer gelée était aussi vous
savez comme moi que vous souvenez comme
moi à la fois de l'étendue des
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
lorsque nous sommes élu maire je ne
pense pas d'ailleurs dit dans votre cas
ni dans le mien que cela ne faisait
jamais empêché de prendre des décisions
en veillant dans toute la mesure du
possible à respecter la loi et en ne
cherchant jamais d'ailleurs à s'exonérer
des responsabilités qui étaient les
nôtres pense que de ce point de vue nous
sommes bien alignés vous avez raison de
dire que la perspective du déconfinement
interroge mais parfois inquiète beaucoup
de nos concitoyens parce que le virus
fait peur parce que beaucoup d'inconnues
subsistent encore à la fois sur l'impact
médical sur la réalité de ce virus sur
ses modes de transmission mais aussi
parce que après une aussi longue période
de déconfinement reprendre une vie
normale même prudemment même
progressivement et forcément quelque
chose qui inquiète vous avez raison
d'indiquer que vous avez entendu nous
avons entendu nous sommes saisis de très
nombreuses interrogations formulées
parfois par les mères parfois par des
responsables associatifs parfois par des
chefs d'entreprises parfois par des
responsables administratifs qui
s'interroge sur les bonnes décisions à
prendre et qui parfois mais à titre
infiniment subsidiaire s'interrogent sur
la mise en cause de la responsabilité
qui pourra être la leur quart jeudi 1
je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas important
mais je dis qu en général ceux qui ont
des décisions à prendre se pose d'abord
la question de savoir si la décision
qu'ils vont prendre est bonne et ensuite
de savoir si le cas échéant on pourrait
venir leur reprocher je pense que c'est
l'expérience que vous avez là aussi
ge indiqué à cette tribune mardi à
l'occasion de la présentation du plan de
déconfinement que ces questions et est
sérieuse et qu'il fallait les traiter
sérieusement et que j'entendais
parfaitement que le parlement bien
entendu dans son pouvoir souverain
puisse essayer d'y apporter des
améliorations mais j'ai également
indiqué monsieur le sénateur je pense
que vous l'avez bien entendu que aussi
bien j'étais parfaitement favorable à ce
que on précise le droit existant qui est
déjà très protecteur grâce au sénat
d'ailleurs qu' il y a vingt ans a permis
à ce que la responsabilité des décideurs
comme on le dit parfois avec un peu de
facilité dans le langage soit beaucoup
mieux encadrer de façon à ce que leur
responsabilité ne soit pas trop
facilement trop systématiquement
recherchée dans des cas où il ne pouvait
pas être tenu responsable
je crois que ce dispositif est beau je
crois que s'agissant de la réouverture
des écoles c'est l'état qui prend la
responsabilité de les ré ouvrir c'est
l'état qui a fermé les écoles et c'est
l'état qui décidera de les ré ouvrir
c'est une responsabilité de l'état
précisé que ce soit s'agissant de la
responsabilité civile ou de la
responsabilité pénale
le régime de responsabilité parce qu'il
faudrait inclure dans la loi des choses
qui sont déjà dans la jurisprudence
ou parce qu'il faudrait préciser qui
sait qu' on ne peut prendre des
décisions qu'en l'état actuel des
connaissances scientifiques par exemple
s'agissant d'une épidémie sans doute
mais atténuer la responsabilité atténuée
monsieur le sénateur la responsabilité
d'une catégorie de décideurs ou même de
tous les décideurs ne me semble pas une
bonne idée
je le dis comme je le pense en étant
conscient que chez beaucoup de mères ma
réponse peut susciter des interrogations
voire même des oppositions
je pense monsieur le sénateur
si nous donnions le sentiment ou plus
encore si effectivement nous atteignons
la responsabilité des décideurs nous ne
rentrions pas service à notre pays nous
ne redonne n'aurions pas confiance à nos
concitoyens et je me permets donc de
dire clairement que je ne m'inscris pas
du tout dans une logique d'atténuation
de la responsabilité
le parlement s'agissant du sénat s'est
exprimé la position du gouvernement a
été donné clairement l'assemblée
nationale va être saisie du texte tel
qu'il est issu du sénat
j'ai tendance à penser que le débat sera
intéressant moi je fais confiance à la
navette
je fais confiance à la discussion entre
les assemblées j'ai toujours fait
confiance à ce débat mais je vous ai dit
quelle était la position du gouvernement
je le dis love sont la plus claire
possible mais je pense monsieur le
sénateur qu'ils font songer y compris
dans ces moments d'angoissé
il y compris dans ces moments à ce que
pensent nos concitoyens de ce que nous
ferions
[Applaudissements]
le sud arnaud lui seul oui monsieur le
premier ministre
certes c'est l'état qui prend la
responsabilité et vous ne pouvez pas
méconnaître que ce sont les maires qui
seront à la manoeuvre y compris
lorsqu'il s'agira dans le temps scolaire
de mettre en place des programmes qui
sont périscolaire et que l'agilité que
vous leur demandez n'est pas une chose
simple et je pense que si vous voulez
que ceux des confinement si vous voulez
que cette rentrée scolaire se passe de
la meilleure façon
alors il faut plus que jamais renouer le
lien de la confiance c'est cette
confiance qui permettra toutes les
formes de réussite jour merci merci
[Applaudissements]